bonsoir
sanuki bojan movies qui tient movies
keziah télé revue des movies qui ont
buté voir tomber c'est ça hein
non papa bonjour papa chez surpris
qu'est ce qu'il vient faire ici est
souvenu de voir du beau voir sa tombe
est un nom parce que quand il est parti
de la maison s'était dit quelque chose
moi hein
est-ce que je suis dit quelque chose
j'ai rien dit et quand il a voulu
changer de nom j'te dis quelque chose
moi 1 est ce qu'il s'est dit quelque
chose
non sourit c'est quand la télévision
j'ai rien dit c'est vrai que maymou
c'est pas très français
je cherche du travail surtout moins
étudiaient bonjour monsieur je m'appelle
maymou soirée
mais de là à choisir anatole france mon
fils tu t'es trompé c'est comme le fils
du monde c'est faisable et mohamed
benabdallah
il abrite honoré de balzac tu croit
qu'il suffit de prendre le nom des
français pour que le sang qui coule dans
ses veines des leçons de la france
monfils cas que l' enveloppe tu aura
jamais la lettre qui est à l'intérieur
à la limite si ce timbre et c'est tout
thiam bt11 tian béteille t'embête ton
père non papa non papa je suis embêté
mais papa essaye de comprendre on est en
france maintenant en 1984 papa j'en ai
marre des différents jeanny marc de cet
accent pape à chaque fois que j'essaye
de dire je t'aime à une femme elle
rigole papa qui a envie d'être français
tu comprend 911 et voilà je vais être
clair
papa tu est bourguignon un bourguignon
même un bâtiment et parvis est une
mauvaise chose du fougeroux regroupe
bourguignonne comment simoni d1 comme ça
veut dire on peut changer se veut dire
le noir américain il peut devenir breton
quelle idée
alors pourquoi tout le monde tu chance
toi tu prends bourguignon tu sais ce que
je prends moi le dernier des mohicans
mais tu sais pas ce que je fais j'avoue
marqué ma jeunesse et je te tue qui a
embêté monfils 1-1 qui ont pété il est
gros ton père un écriteau perrin et les
vulgaires tomber dit le tout simplement
dit le papa jérôme de toi dis le
je te gêne m'ont prise voilà je m'en
vais
je m'en vais
mais ils veulent dire quelque chose
encore mais si jamais joué prend en main
complète de bras
les deux ans les gestes aux quatre
points cardinaux et le reste de mon
corps on le laisse pour ici sans dents
mais seulement si je me trompe mais dans
la vie en un coup
un seul et même s'il te plaît pas même
si les nord africains
il faut essayer de l'enfoncer toujours
le même
et toi qu'est ce tu fais mon fils tu va
enfoncer le clou des autres alors tu
peux me dire quand ta maison elle va se
construire
je m'en vais mon pays
je m'en vais
et quoi tu parles
rokia même s'ils changent de nom au
moment où s'y attendra le moins j'ai
surgirait 7 après sur l'épaule mais
c'est à dire et aubrystes tient des
terrains
l'oubli
n'oublie jamais nous je m'en vais
je m'en veux